die russische invasion der ukraine geht
nun bereits in die dritte woche und die
lage verschärft sich immer weiter ein
berater des ukrainischen präsidialamtes
teilte mit dass das land sich auf eine
neue welle von angriffen auf chf und die
don was gebiete ein stelle in der nähe
von kiew ist einem medienbericht zufolge
am samstagmorgen ein ukrainischer
luftwaffenstützpunkt durch russischen
raketen beschuss zerstört wurden auch
ein munitionslager invasiv sei getroffen
worden zitierte der ukrainische ableger
der russischen nachrichtenagentur
interfax die bürgermeisterin des orts
vitali klitschko bürgermeister von kiew
betonte am freitag dass die hauptstadt
der ukraine auf eine einkesselung durch
die russische armee gut vorbereitet sei
vor dem krieg lebten 3,5 millionen
menschen in kiew jetzt da ein teil der
frauen und kinder aus kiew weg ist
schätzen wir dass es noch immer fast
zwei millionen menschen in kiew gibt und
es ist sehr wichtig für die menschen da
zu sein wir haben strom heizung gas wir
haben wasser was wir nicht akzeptieren
werden sind angriffe die die logistik
zerstören
die ukrainischen behörden
veröffentlichten am freitag aufnahmen
einer überwachungskamera die russische
truppen bei der festnahme des
bürgermeisters von milito pohl zeigen
sollen einer stadt im südosten der
ukraine die während der invasion unter
russische kontrolle fiel
das außenministerium der ukraine
beschuldigte russland in einer erklärung
der verletzung des völkerrechts durch
die entführung des bürgermeisters iwand
fedorov unabhängig überprüfen kann man
die echtheit des videos nicht nach
angaben des britischen
verteidigungsministeriums toben die
kämpfe am samstag nordwestlich von kiew
wobei der großteil der russischen
bodentruppen 25 kilometer vom zentrum
der ukrainischen hauptstadt entfernt war
während mehrere andere städte
eingekreist worden
und unter schweren beschuss standen